overnight Moscow claimed more than 60
Russian prisoners of War were released
from Ukrainian captivity right now the
two nations are locked in Fierce
fighting in the embattled eastern city
of Bak moots we're learning more about
American medic and Marine veteran Pete
Reed who was killed in bakmut this week
Reed's Widow told CBS the 34 year old
was helping civilians evacuate when his
ambulance was struck by Russian shelling
Deborah patta has more on the battle for
back Moot and how technology is crucial
to the fight
let's go
nothing is safe in Bahamut
once home to 70 000 people nearly a year
of War has left a hollowed out shell
artillery is constant here the sound
fills the air the city is absolutely
decimated and deserted barring a few
people astoundingly we've seen still
trying to eat out of living here
those who stayed fear leaving more than
dying even a visit to the Central Square
is done with one eye on the clock the
other on the sky
[Music]
to the east a blood-soaked battlefield
where Russian games are counted in
inches
in the west Bahamut still holds
ukrainians say but only just Cartier
commanders takes us to an underground
Command Center where an army of tech
Geeks turned Warriors scan multiple
video feeds of the front line beamed
back in real time a fleet of inexpensive
drones provides a bird's eye view of the
battlefield in astonishing detail like
this dead Russian soldier sprawled on
the roadside and shattered backyards
where the kremlin's troops were recently
filmed crawling for cover to escape a
Ukrainian grenade sophisticated 21st
century electronic surveillance meets
the savagery of world war one trench
warfare
we have units that take the drones up
into the sky and stream video here third
operative Brigade Commander Alexander
pivnenko explained it's used to support
artillery we see the enemy advance and
Destroy them
officers here say Russia throws waves of
soldiers like meat into the fight
they just keep on advancing over the
bodies of their fallen soldiers third
operative of the Italian Commander Anton
Zara rogini said one group has destroyed
another is sent in
the men work sleep and eat here in
shifts around the clock no job to menial
because even though Russian forces have
been killed in staggering numbers trying
to take this small City these Ukrainian
soldiers no more will come and more will
die on both sides but for now from this
bunker to the blood-soaked battlefields
just a few blocks away
for CBS Saturday morning Deborah patter
Bachman